captain pete maverick mitchell you were
here at the request of iceman he seems
to think that you have something left to
offer the navy
with all due respect sir
i'm not a teacher just want to manage
expectations
what the hell good morning aviators this
is your captain speaking
i intend to push your limits
show me what you're made of nice
whoa having any fun yet
top gun maverick new trailer online now
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman he seems to think that you
have something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
you all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage the expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
here we go
in three
two
one going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots
anything happens to them
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
having any fun yet
[Music]
you